all right moving on the growing
popularity of so-called kid influencers
is raising questions about the potential
impact of sharing children's lives
online these social media stars promote
products on Instagram and make millions
posting short video blogs known as vlogs
a recent study found about one in three
American kids between the ages of eight
and twelve aspire to be either a vlogger
or a youtuber Forbes reports the
highest-paid YouTube star last year with
seven-year-old Ryan who earned
twenty-two million dollars in just 12
months people he hosts a popular toy
review channel on the site the latest
CBS n original kid influencers few rules
big money looks inside the estimated 4.6
billion dollar influencer business it
includes interviews with families of
these young influencers it's a lot of
work it's a full-time job
but it's not really a job because
they're having fun my mom's here cuz
because we're shooting on the East Coast
and she's from the East Coast she comes
along but she's skeptical because it's
all
like it was for us maybe this is my
fourth or fifth shoot it gives them a
lot of great opportunities I see them
being able to relate to adults and
experiencing things that I could never
even imagine so it's kind of a great
thing in that respect but I don't know
the other side of it I don't know what
how that's going to influence them as
they get older I would say that I do
share the concerns that my mom has but
not so she's very dramatic they're
little girls I want them to stay like
that psychiatrist dr. sue Varma is here
with the biggest issues for these social
media stars and whether your kids should
be following them online good morning so
there are the kids who are in the videos
and then there are the kids who are
watching them for the kids who are in
the videos are there psychological risks
for parents putting them out there like
that children that are social media
stars are contending with all of the
social pressures of being children in a
digital age combined with being a child
star and we know that child stars are
more likely to have anxiety depression
substance issues later on in life
because they're dealing with their sense
of self-esteem being linked to public
approval career success right and the
hits and the likes and there's an
intoxication there's a almost like an
addiction to it and they don't have the
coping skills to deal with failure and
disappointment there are rules for kids
who work on a film or TV set but but
there aren't really rules for this are
there no and it's really concerning
because anytime you have a family
business look the child in this case is
the product right when does it end it's
a 24/7 job and I'm concerned about where
two parents who have to gain financially
from this how do they set the rules and
I'm troubled by this because the
intrusive nature it's 24/7 and the
parents are supposed to be protecting
them in this case are obviously over
sharing sometimes although to be fair
that many of the parents say look we're
making a lot of money but kids cost a
lot of money and this is going to
college and everything else so is that a
good counterpoint no you know I I don't
think so I think that parents have to be
the ones to protect their kids and the
problem is that right now in a digital
age to achieve success it is
with endless and merciless and where are
we going to teach our kids the values
right this is really promoting instant
gratification at the expense I think of
substance and depth and these kids don't
have any other experience this is all
that they know because some of these
kids are babies that are having to be
posted online and you probably get that
validation from the likes and all of
that but what about the other kids who
are watching these videos and idolizing
these kids that look like their lives
are perfect what's the impact on them
yeah so the kids we have to make people
realize that our sense of mastery and
self-esteem has to come from a variety
of things sports leadership in the
community leadership in your schools
this is not the be-all and end-all and
I'm concerned when more kids want to be
youtubers as opposed to astronauts and
the fact that we are letting our kids
have too much screen time kids when
they're spending time with other
children should not be on their screen
they should be outside playing this it
is a form of bringing people together
but it's not the only form all right dr.
sue Varma thanks so much for being with
us this morning you can watch the latest
CBS n originals documentary kid in
fluids influencers few rules big money
streaming now on CBS news.com slash
influencers